this year as we look towards our next
aspire to lead global video webcast
we're going to touch upon the topic of
confidence you know they're consistent
research findings that show that men
tend to overestimate their competence
and women underestimate their competence
research has also shown that women are
actually more competent leaders and that
startups with women at the helm that
boards with more women on them and that
organizations with greater gender
diversity outperform their competitors
understand that if you aspire to a
career a profession a leadership role in
many respects you're going to be judged
and evaluated on your ability to bring
out the best in others to create a work
environment that's truly inclusive that
allows the best ideas to percolate and
to come from all members of your team
your organization and to do these things
to bring out the best in others we've
got to start by bringing out the best in
ourselves by building self awareness
understanding our own implicit beliefs
the stereotypes we carry around that can
hold us back and hold others as well